well it is a challenge in that it is
something that people can focus on and
but it has not in 25 years done what
some of thought might happen you say gee
the New York Times back before 80 said
the Reagan is attracting all these
people who have jobs and want lower
taxes and all these people who go to
church and want to be left alone by the
secular state they're going to fight any
minute now well why what are they going
to fight over in point of fact there
will be many discussions inside a
majoritarian movement with 300 million
people in the country if you're going to
deserve the votes of 175 million people
they're not going to agree on everything
try and get six people to agree what
restaurant to go to for dinner so you're
going to have people who disagree on
secondary or tertiary issues but the
coalition holds because even though the
guy who's there and wants to be left
alone to practice his faith if you ask
him 20 questions and you take the guy
who wants to be left alone to run his
business and you ask them 20 questions
they may have very different answers on
question 7 8 and 10 but I don't care I'm
on the board of the National Rifle
Association I can assure you that a lot
of the people who vote on the Second
Amendment have what I consider to be the
oddest views on free trade but they
don't vote on free trade so one level I
don't I don't care what they think about
free trade
canon looked in two thousand and said
seventy percent of republicans think
they're too many immigrants seventy
percent of republicans are skeptics on
free trade with china i will run for
president as the anti-trade
anti-immigrant canada gets understand
the vote what he didn't ask was not what
are you willing to talk about on talk
radio but what moves you vote and in
point of fact there wasn't a net
anti-immigrant anti-trade vote within
the Republican coalition and he got
almost Novus didn't get one percent of
the electorate so what people are
willing to talk about and what they vote
on are not the same things necessarily
as you have to watch and see how people
vote now you have some guys who are in
the coalition or and claim to represent
large quantities of people Pat Robertson
would say I represent some of the people
of faith okay well he may represent some
of them in so far as he says we would
like to be left alone and not have the
the state throw prophylactics at our
kids at school and not interfere with
our ability to transmit our faith but if
he was to say oh and by the way I think
we should go to San Francisco I mean
mean to gay people his voters don't
follow him on that and they are not
willing to cross the street to impose
their views on others I mean if you said
them do you think everybody should agree
with you on everything oh yes they
should are you willing you want the
state to go make them if you think if
you think everybody would go to heaven
better if they were Baptist are you
willing to have the state imposed that
just talking the other day the head of
the Southern Baptist Convention who said
no of course not that's that's not their
view there are some people who the press
will always focus on who have tastes
take out an extreme position and who fib
when they say and everybody in my church
agrees with me let's just not true and B
you need to be careful about people
claiming that they have to have x y&z to
be part of the coalition the person
who's in the coalition because he wants
to be left alone to practice his faith
and raise his kids
is not if you tell them well the state
isn't going to go subsidize your church
he's not gonna walk out the door and
join the secular party that that does
want to interfere with his ability to
raise this kid there isn't any there
there's no alternative political
structure to join for somebody who would
like to be left alone with their guns
plus you know don't want to be left
alone i want gun stamps yeah you may
want gun stamps but you don't vote on
guns do you vote on being left alone
would you like 12 other things would you
like two desserts maybe okay or is there
some other place to go get two desserts
no so you are where you are because you
want to be left alone you can ask people
all sorts of odd questions and get all
sorts of odd answers on a lot of stuff
doesn't make it a vote moving issue
although certainly on talk radio or if
you you know put Jerry Falwell on on on
Fox TV he can say things that scare
people into thinking oh my goodness the
religious people if they they want to do
X well I would argue that when you
actually look at how the center-right
coalition movement operates taxpayers
and businessmen don't want the state to
go steal people's money and give it to
them they want the state stop stealing
their money people of faith don't want
the state to impose their values they
don't want their values attacked by the
secular state
you